whatever it takes whatever it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
hi everyone its charlie now that we've
gotten a couple Avengers and game
trailers I've got a lot of questions
about who the new most powerful Avengers
characters are so I did a new ranking
one of the most fun things to do every
new Avenger cycle every couple of years
characters get power-ups new characters
come in that are way more powerful so
the purposes of this list I'm just
talking about Avengers characters that
are either part of the original six
their official new avengers or will
become new avengers as Kevin Feige has
set it so I'm not including temporary
Avengers like the guardians of the
galaxy like Nebula and Rocket are in the
avengers base wearing those white suits
with the Avengers so they're gonna be
working together but for the purposes of
this list those characters don't count
and I also take into account temporary
powerup forms because there are
modifiers there are characters that
wield Infinity stones at times so that's
all part of this list this will be
broken into tears because a lot of them
are basically the same power level
unless there's some modifier in play
like they're wielding an infinity stone
or they happen to get the Infinity
Gauntlet we do Marvel videos every week
be sure to subscribe to get everything
it's only gonna get crazier as we head
into Avengers and game spider-man far
from home and all the Marvel phase 4
stuff now that they have all the Fox and
Fantastic Four characters there's also
new giveaway stuff that I'll explain at
the end of the video but starting at the
bottom tier 6 we'll call it you have
Hawkeye Black Widow in Falcon all very
intelligent very capable fighters Black
Widow and Hawkeye some of the best
assassins in the world the reason why
they're at the bottom and the reason why
they're relatively the same is because
their basic humans they have no big
powerup forms they're not the guardian
of any of the Infinity stones and they
didn't get their powers from an infinity
stone yes we do see Black Widow and
Hawkeye wearing the white quantum suits
that Ironman makes for all the Avengers
the reason why I don't count those is
because one we don't know exactly how
they're going to be using them we only
have a couple of theories and they
wouldn't be wearing those all the time
anyway they're not naturally that
powerful tier 5 next step up is Captain
America in Winter Soldier both powered
by a version of the Super Soldier Serum
both amazing fighters badass which is
not quite as powerful as some of the
newer characters that they've introduced
who are all
so biologically powered we're all hoping
that Captain America is gonna wheel
Thor's hammer or storm breaker at some
point during the film but that wouldn't
be something that he would normally have
all the time so you can't count stuff
like that either
next up up is tier 4 where you have
characters like ant-man in spider-man
ant-man is crazy powerful they just make
him seem like a bumbling idiot who can't
do anything he's actually an engineer
he's a very smart person it just that
the story uses him more as a comedian
the reason why he's higher than say like
Captain America and Winter Soldier is
because he has Pym particles all the
time and he's the one that gives them
access to the quantum energy so the
reason why he isn't super high on the
list because quantum energy is crazy
powerful is because he wouldn't have
that all the time it isn't quite figured
out how to use it the reason why
spider-man is next to him on this list
to this is because his natural
biological powers make him more powerful
than people like Captain America even
when he's just a 16 year old kid he's
able to fight him off
[Music]
the reason why Captain America is able
to beat him is is because he has years
and years of experience on him he just a
way better fighter it's not that he's
stronger or more powerful that's not
even counting spider-man's special suits
the suits themselves can make him a
little bit more powerful so technically
you could count those but we don't know
about all the future suits that they're
gonna put him in in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in the future films but above
them Tier three you have Iron Man black
panther and vision who now no longer has
an infinity stone pretty obvious why
Iron Man and black panther are about
equal Iron Man is a genius and black
panther is incredibly smart - surely
technically a little bit smarter and
makes all of his technology they're
people that functionally have unlimited
resources in access to their special
powerup technology at all times like you
would expect Black Panther to be wearing
his suit in a fight you'd expect Iron
Man to have a brand new suit in a fight
just think about Iron Man's fight with
Thanos on Titan he had a couple Infinity
stones all that for drop of blood he was
still able to fight Thanos to a
standstill briefly before he got pounded
vibranium is a bit of an x-factor just
to make an x-men joke now that they own
all those characters in that you don't
know exactly how many different things
that they'll be able to use it for in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so Black
Panther is one of those characters like
ant-man that has access to some special
science and technology above that of
what the other characters have that also
give him a lot of extra power the reason
why vision is on the list next to them
is because he did lose the Infinity
stone so he's not cosmic level powered
anymore but he's made of vibranium so
he's virtually indestructible unless
you're wielding an infinity stone or the
Infinity Gauntlet like Thanos his
advanced Android brain also makes him
one of the smartest people on the planet
so his way faster way stronger way
smarter than most other characters but
he has about the same level of
technology that you would expect Black
Panther Sheree in Iron Man to have we
should also probably include war machine
in this tier just because he's using
Iron Man's technology albeit
hand-me-down technology so he's not
quite as powerful as Iron Man but he's
really close next tier up you're getting
closer to cosmic level beings this is
tier two Doctor Strange Captain Marvel
Scarlet Witch in the Hulk so
reason why they're all relatively about
the same as is because dr. strange has
lost the time stone but as of Avengers
infinity war Kevin Feige and the
producers confirm that he's the most
powerful sorcerer in the universe he was
also able to fight Thanos to a
standstill while he was wielding a
couple of the Infinity stones the only
reason why he gave up is is to save Iron
Man's life and because of that one in 14
million plan he had to throw the match
so that they would lose the battle so
that they could later win the war there
was no other way after all of this in
Marvel phase four even if he does not
get the time stone back and isn't will
be an infinity stone all the time which
additionally makes him way more powerful
you would still reasonably expect him to
have access to and use any kind of
magical artifact like the staff of The
Living Tribunal magic that is so
powerful that you have to bind it to an
object it's just like Ant Man using Pym
particles you would reasonably expect
ant-man to have Pym particles all the
time Captain Marvel is on the list
because of our binary form if you
haven't seen the Captain Marvel movie or
you haven't read the comics binary form
is a temporary powerup level that she
can achieve where she gives off the
level of energy that you would see in a
binary system and that's a system with
two stars that orbit each other remember
when Thor went to the dwarfs to forge
Stormbreaker and had to reignite the
star so that the Forge would work
that's one star imagine two giant
versions of that at the same time coming
from the same being but it's a very
temporary form she can't output that
level of energy the entire time she has
to absorb enough energy to get there and
there aren't that many things that could
power her up for that long there are
only a few other characters that
actually output energy that would work
really well with her like Iron Man's arc
reactor could blast her with enough
energy to power her up Thor could use
his lightning to power her up she can
give off a giant single burst that'll
drain all of her power she can give it
off slowly she can use it to strengthen
her body the amount of time she could
sustain that level just depends on how
quickly she's outputting energy and
giving off big blasts the reason why
Scarlet Witch is here obviously because
she's also powered by an infinity stone
Captain Marvel the space stone Scarlet
Witch the mines don't each new movie she
comes back she's more powerful just
because she's learned more about her
abilities become more in tune with them
but at maximum level she could do just
about as much
image is Captain Marvel could the reason
why the hook is on this level is because
of the way his power works he just gets
stronger and stronger as he gets matter
in matter the reason why he lost during
infinity war the ruses have explained is
that one it was unexpected and it was
mostly to make Thanos seem even more
badass because he was beating him
without an infinity stone but it's one
of those situations whereby Thor got
more powerful after thor ragnarok
because he learned the truth of his
abilities and became more in tune with
them it's the same thing with banner in
the Hulk the Hulk can become more
powerful but it's a question of his
psychological state in embracing that
power to its fullest extent when people
talk about world breaker Hulk though
that's actually a temporary power of
form when he becomes Herald of Galactus
in the comics in not expecting any of
the original Avengers or the New
Avengers to become heralds of Galactus
anytime soon moving to top tier you
probably figured out by now number one
is Thor he will become the new most
powerful Avenger moving into phase four
because of what's happening during
Avengers endgame in the role that he's
transitioning to in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe strongest Avenger strongest
Avenger
so what's happened since the events of
Thor Ragnarok Odin has died he is now
the new king of Asgard even though
technically Asgard was destroyed as they
kept saying Asgard is not a place it's a
people Thor is powered by his people
they're still as Guardians out there
hiding in the nine realms so Asgard
still exists Stormbreaker made him
unbelievably powerful it's one of the
most powerful weapons in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now so that in
addition to his own natural level of
ability made him way more powerful you
would expect him to be wielding that at
any given time that's not even the end
of it Thor's getting even more powerful
because he is the new All Father it's
just there a couple of things that have
to happen before he has granted the
fullness of his abilities he's King Thor
but technically in name only because
he's separated from his people there
been a lot of questions about Odin in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
he's one of the most powerful people in
the Marvel comic book universe
remember when Heimdall called on the all
fathers during infinity war to grant him
the dark energy to create a Bifrost out
of thin air to port Hulk back to Planet
Earth eventually Thor will gain that
same power he even tells Odin during
Thor Ragnarok when he's fighting hella
and he talks to Odin
she's too much I'm not powerful enough
I'm not as powerful as you you know Dan
says no you're not
you're stronger there was a little bit
of a pet talk but he was also speaking
literally Thor now is more powerful than
Odin because he has all of Auden's power
and his own natural abilities as well
and he is a legit God in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the reason why he
doesn't seem that powerful during
Avengers infinity war is because they
want him to seem like he has weaknesses
that's why he'll is able to take his eye
out because she's also on that same
level of power too
they want to give him a lot of problems
he has to deal with so he's at his
lowest point and he has nothing left to
lose that's why it's gonna be so much
fun to watch him Unchained
during Avengers end game but after that
he will go find his people he will
officially become King Thor Chris
Hemsworth said that he's going to be
coming back during Marvel phase 4 even
though they haven't officially announced
plans for a fourth Thor film they might
wind up doing that at some point but
effectively he's transitioning to more
of a background role as the all-father
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe bonus
tears though are celestial beings like
the only level above that would be to
legit be a celestial being had the
guardians of the galaxy not killed ego
the Living Planet then Peter quill could
one day have become just as powerful as
that as long as ego remains dead he
doesn't have access to that celestial
energy he's bottom tier with Hawkeye
Black Widow and Falcon but like I said
I'm not including the guardians on this
list and I'm not talking about other
cosmic beings like eternity which would
be even more powerful than people like
Dormammu I know there's a billion
Avengers and gain questions so if you
have any questions about relative power
levels just post them in the comments
below
my non-spoilery Shazam review will post
tonight look out for that there is a new
round to the IMAX ticket giveaway - as
long as you're a subscriber to the
channel all you have to do is just leave
a comment about the Avengers on the
video while you wait for all that click
here for my brand new Avengers endgame
trailer video and learn all about the
Fox Disney deal and what's happening
with those characters next and click
here to learn all about Thanos during
Avengers endgame thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]